now the government has turned down a
recommendation from The Commons women's
and equalities committee to trial
menopausal leave warning it could be
counterproductive the chair of the
committee is urging ministers to
reconsider
we know that in the region of a million
women have already been lost to the
workplace because of the menopause
symptoms that they've gone through
my message to the government is this is
going to happen to Every Woman we will
all go through the menopause and if we
want women over 50 to continue to be
economically productive then we have to
find better ways to support them
one thing to say we're joined Now by
Penny Lancaster an ambassador for the
well-being of women at charity Penny
Lancaster good morning to you and thank
you for being with us uh what was your
reaction when you heard the government's
decision on this
ah gosh just deflated really
um I mean
women of 50 and over are the highest
demographic
um in the workplace
um over 80 of uh NHS workers are female
um and it and it seems that you know of
course not every single woman suffers
but at least three and four women suffer
symptoms and some very very serious and
we can't really afford to lose those
highly qualified experienced women in
the workplace that's why it's so
important that charity like well-being
women have a pledge for companies to
sign up to a promise to their workers
that they will support them in their
working environment giving them advice
um and a room to to talk um not just
amongst women but to have that open
dialogue with men and women uh workshops
that will help them
um give them exercise advice diet advice
but the the sad thing is that if if the
workplace doesn't help women with the
menopause then they will start reducing
their hours they'll won't consider
promotion and they'll even go to the
point where they will quit jobs just
because of the extreme symptoms that
menopause can have yeah this is a time
when the government is saying he wants
to get people over the age of 50 back
into the workforce so what is it that
employers needs to be doing to help
women are going through menopause
well-being of women are a charity that
specialize in all sort of welfare for
women
um especially the menopause and the
pledge that the speaker of the house
actually signed that we were thrilled
that they did
um gives a very clear guidelines to what
kind of things the workplace could do to
help women but not only that advice that
comes from the charity but also to
listen to the individuals because each
case is is very different
um I myself
um thought I was suffering from
depression well my doctor thought I was
suffering from depression and I was
prescribed antidepressants but in fact
they didn't help they made things worse
because you end up feeling like you're
going crazy you've got no one to talk to
you feel very Alone
um and in the end it was um I was
diagnosed that it was in fact the
menopause and I was luckily put on HRT
and it's been life-changing so more
women need that guidance and help and
and particular support in the workplace
I've very fortunate where I work in the
city of London Police they've already
set up coffee mornings there's the
exercise program and just being able to
have that open dialogue in which
normally is a very male orientated place
um they're very open and willing to to
help and support women
well I'm pleased to say pleased to hear
um Penny Lancaster that you've got the
the help and support that you need I
want to come onto the city of London
Police in a moment but just
just to describe
or people like me need to understand
about what it's like going through the
menopause
well as I say there's a range of
symptoms but
um I guess the worst one is is just a
the anxiety and fear because you do get
a brain fog
um and so when you're in the workplace
and you've got a meeting or
um you've got to do some research
um the brain fog can obviously affect
that
um you you get moments dips of
depression
um where you feel like not motivated and
you can't get up in the morning uh
there's symptoms of of course the very
common which is sort of physically you
see women getting those hot flushes and
it's almost gets to the point where you
feel like having a panic attack so
unless you talk to other women that are
going through a similar thing or people
in your Workforce have got an
understanding
um Mentor then you do feel lost and um
the fear ends up kind of you you just
want to give up
hmm
yeah thank you for that opinion I want I
wonder
um off topic but since we have you and
since you say you worked as a volunteer
at the city of London Police I wonder
how it's been in the police force in the
past week or so since we've had those
Revelations about this metropolitan
police officers
um as a woman working in the force
what's have you noticed any shift in
attitude in the past few days and how
has it been
um well it's something that I wouldn't
really want to comment on
um the Met police is very separate from
the city of London
um I know that we we do a lot of work
um gearing up specifically for crimes
related to women violence domestic abuse
um so we're very hot on that topic
um in this in the city of London but uh
I wouldn't want to comment on those
specifics no I understand that uh Penny
thank you so much for your time this
morning and all the very best in your
campaign I know that Caroline notes is
still pushing for this so uh maybe the
government will listen thank you